-Our first guest is an
Emmy-winning
comedian and the host of
"The Sarah Silverman Podcast."
You can also see her
in the new film "Marry Me,"
in theaters and streaming on
Peacock February 11th.
Here is Sarah Silverman!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi! Yeah!
-What's up?!
-Oh! Can you feel the love from
New York for Sarah Silverman?
-Hi!
-Hi, bud.
-I brought you a gift.
-Oh, you -- Thank you.
-Yeah, because it's close
to Valentine's Day,
and the movie "Marry Me"
comes out on Valentine's Day.
-Yep.
-And I know you like chocolate.
And so I thought
I'd just give you this.
But I'm not there, I realized.
-Yeah, I thought someone
was going to
bring it out to me
or something, but no.
Yeah.
-No.
-I'll just, like, ASMR it.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my --
-Oh, my God!
-Oh, please.
Well, you know what it is?
It's the thought --
-You would love this.
-You know what it is?
It's the thought
that counts, Sarah.
How many chocolates
are in that box?
-I only ate one,
but then I was like,
"I can't swallow it whole."
-That's true, yeah.
-You have to savor it.
-No, you have to savor it.
Sarah --
-Go on, go on. I'll be ready.
-You're back to doing stand-up,
which I'm excited about.
What things are you
talking about now in your act?
-Can I just do a bit
that isn't even a bit?
-Yeah.
-I don't know what this is.
-Okay. I love this.
-It's something like
if you went up to somebody,
like, you walked up
to a stranger,
and you could say
something like, "Hi.
You don't know me.
Oh, this is so weird.
But I -- Somebody you love
who has passed away
wants you to know
it's not your fault?"
I mean...
-That's fantastic.
-...I just think
it's interesting.
-Wow! They're strangers.
-Because, Jimmy, it's a lie,
but it's also, like, the truth,
you know?
There isn't anybody who
that wouldn't be very moving
and, like,
release them from burdens.
But it is a lie.
Yeah.
-You're alleviating people
from the guilt.
I think it's fantastic.
And I think it's --
I think it's a good bit.
Are you doing any joke,
like, specific joke-jokes?
-Ooh! I wrote, like,
jokey-joke,
like a joke-book kind of joke.
-I love this.
I want to hear this.
-Alright.
-Yes, we love this.
-Okay.
What did the Jewish mother
say to her porn-star daughter
after watching her
in a gangbang?
[ Drumroll ]
-What?
-"You were the best one."
-Oh, my goodness.
I just love that stereotype,
you know,
that Jewish mothers are just so
bananas for their kids.
-They really are.
-"My Sharon, anywhere
you could fit a schmekel,
there was Schmekel.
-Okay!
-Top of her knee, a schmekel.
Her forehead, a schmekel.
You ever seen
a schmekel on an elbow?
The left one, a doctor."
Too much?
-Oh, my gosh.
-I thought I really
cleaned it up for this.
-Oh, my gosh.
Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
[ Applause ]
Applause break.
Applause breaks through Zoom.
You do a thing on your podcast
where you give
advice to listeners.
And I love that
part of your podcast.
Have you always
given advice to people?
Are you good at that?
I mean,
have you always done that?
-Yeah, I think so. I -- Yeah.
I mean, I was just in New York.
My best friend, Heidi,
lives in New York.
You've met her, actually.
And she loves you.
And she was like, "I've had
diarrhea for like three days.
I don't know what is going on."
And then -- You know when
you're in New York --
She had me go into her backpack.
She was like, "Get my water
out of my backpack."
-Yeah.
-And I get her water out.
She has, like, half a bag of
prunes in her backpack.
I was like,
"Heidi, I solved the case.
You're eating prunes."
-Yeah, exactly.
-She's like,
"They're not prunes."
And then she pointed to it.
She goes, "They're dried plums."
I said, "What do you think
prunes are?"
She's like,
"Are they dried plums?"
Yeah. She's a therapist,
by the way.
I just want to point that out.
But I get it.
Like, Big Prune
was probably like,
"We need to rebrand."
-Big Prune.
-People hear "prune,"
they think diarrhea.
So, yeah,
call yourselves dried plums.
I think they should be
called dried plums,
but it should come with
a warning that says like,
"Warning -- these are prunes."
-Prunes. Yes, of course.
Big Prune is taking over.
It's so sad to see that happen.
-Big Prune.
-I want to talk about
your movie, "Marry Me."
The buzz is,
this is going to be --
this is going to bring back
the rom-com.
You're saving
the romantic comedy.
-Jimmy, it's our movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's -- You have Jennifer Lopez.
Anything Jennifer Lopez
in a movie, I'm there.
Jennifer Lopez --
-Same.
-I mean, how fun is it?
How -- She's just the greatest.
-And she's --
By the way, like, you know,
you see her on Instagram, you
see her on TV, and in movies.
And they have filters,
and they do beauty work.
And, yeah, she's beautiful,
but in person --
-In real life. Oh, stunner.
-She's a monster. No.
She is so beautiful.
-She's so stunningly beautiful.
-I mean, I look at her this
close and I'm just like, "How?
How is it possible?"
-And she can sing and
she can dance
and she can -- You do --
-Amazing singer, amazing dancer,
awesome actor.
I love her movies.
-Yeah.
-Anytime her movie is on,
I'm -- I stay there.
She's just -- She's electric.
And then there's Owen Wilson,
who is another favorite,
I mean, but so different,
such a different realm.
Like, his writing, his comedy,
his beautiful acting.
And they're so different, but
it's, like, electric, you know?
-Yeah.
-It really is.
It is bringing back the rom-com.
I think you're so right.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Sarah Silverman,
Jennifer Lopez, and Owen Wilson
in "Marry Me."
Take a look at this.
-Charlie! Come in!
-Oh, she's right there. Jesus.
-Come over, guys.
Charlie, Kat.
Kat, Charlie.
-Hi.
-How are you?
Oh.
[ Chuckles ]
-Okay.
[ Laughs ]
-I'm Parker.
I'm -- I am the one who brought
Charlie to the concert,
so I'm basically --
I guess I'm responsible
for this whole thing.
-Hi, Parker.
-Hey, Kat.
-Hi.
-Would you do me a favor,
uh, just two seconds
and just say,
"Roxy, you really blew it"?
-"Today Show" is a go
at 10:00 on Tuesday.
-Sorry.
-They want, uh, uh...
-Um, Charlie.
-Charlie in studio
and Kat remote from London.
-Kat.
-Excuse me one second.
I just have to take...
-Bye, Kat.
She's, like, a real person.
-What's going on?
-Yeah! She's a real person.
You blew it, Roxy!
Sarah Silverman, everybody!
"Marry Me" is in theaters
and streaming on Peacock
February 11th.